i've never seen this this has been
so impressive and amazing and
leaving teachers with wanting more
when i first knew about khan academy it
was mostly like well my teacher said
this in class but i can't remember what
he said so i'm going to go check out on
khan academy so it's more of a personal
resource and that's kind of where i was
thinking it would be in my classroom
down the line it's like if you're
struggling with this go check out khan
academy but now
as after coming to this it can be that
first step it can be the go-to hey go
learn this
go learn the foundations and then we can
take it to the next level in our
classroom we can put those hands-on
activities
being able to take a child and look and
say wow they're really struggling here
so now when i've got everybody else
doing this i can slip around back
without anybody noticing that i'm
helping somebody because they're slower
and allowing that child to
keep their dignity
because i was able to privately identify
what it was that they needed help with
and that was awesome
i love this whole concept
this is so
life-changing in the way that you teach
because then it gives you time to work
with the students and it gives you time
to understand
what they and what they know and clear
up misconceptions it gives you time to
just really encourage those students to
go on
i have a very unique set of students
they happen to be behind bars in my
classroom i might have a guy that's
functioning at his
second grade level and i may have a guy
that has his phd
sitting in the same classroom and how do
you bridge that gap as a teacher and yet
i saw the khan academy being a tool that
we could implement
at a very low cost with our economy the
way it is and provides biggest bang for
the buck
empowering the student to learn is what
the key is to making them learn for for
life and so i think this is a great
aspect and a great tool of that i think
it'll actually start helping them to
to say hey if i don't know the answer i
can find it because that's kind of what
i try to do in my classroom and i think
we need to do more of that
the way kids learn now is the way kind
of education is going has been kind of
status quo for many years now and i
think they really are on the front edge
of some
new innovative solutions to helping kids
learn
and catching up with you know not only
the rest of the nation but the rest of
the world i feel like
my students are the revolution
you